Avant que la vidéo ne commence,
j’ai une question à vous poser :
vous croyez VRAIMENT
que les gens ont lu
tous les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non.
— sinon on ne pourrait pas parler
de grand-chose.
Eh oui,
il y a vingt-quatre heures
dans une journée,
et il faut travailler,
manger,
dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS
de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret,
il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes
les plus cultivés,
les profs,
et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT
ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien
d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer
RAPIDEMENT
et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale,
parce que leur rapport au savoir
A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets,
ils comprennent toutes les références
des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture
dans les conversations
et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d’esprit
critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique
comment les appliquer
DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver
DIX FOIS PLUS RAPIDEMENT
SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets,
inscrivez-vous simplement
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de dix secondes,
donc faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail
après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà,
je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Je vous laisse regarder la vidéo,
et moi je vais promener Haristote.
________________
1ère référence : De l'esprit
des lois, Montesquieu
Pourquoi commencer par Montesquieu ? Parce
qu’il passe, notamment avec cet ouvrage,
pour un précurseur, voire pour le
fondateur de la sociologie.
Après, c’est vrai qu’il a été beaucoup de choses.
Vous le connaissez certainement comme un des plus
célèbres philosophes des Lumières, avec Voltaire,
Rousseau, et Diderot. La tradition académique
française ne sait pas trop où le ranger
: homme de lettres, théoricien politique,
historien du droit, idéologue qui a préparé
la Révolution française. Keynes dit, lui,
que Montesquieu est « le plus grand économiste
français », et il le compare à Adam Smith,
dans la préface de la Théorie générale.
On ne range donc pas spontanément Montesquieu
dans le champ intellectuel de la sociologie,
qu’on peut définir comme l’étude de la société
et des phénomènes sociaux à partir de leurs
propriétés propres. Et il y a des raisons
évidentes à cela : le mot « sociologie »
n’existait pas à l’époque ; Montesquieu
parle d’une société révolue, pas de la société
industrielle dans laquelle naîtra la sociologie
en tant que discipline académique ; et enfin il se
sert des idées de la philosophie politique.
Et pourtant, sa démarche, dans De l'esprit des
lois, est bien sociologique : il identifie les
causes profondes qui expliquent l’évolution
générale des sociétés, puis il regroupe la grande
diversité de lois et de mœurs qu’il observe
dans le monde dans quelques catégories.
Et il fait ça sans le jargon sociologique
qui donnera des maux de tête aux lecteurs
des futurs sociologues professionnels. Le
style de Montesquieu est très agréable : ses
phrases sont simples ; il suit une logique
démonstrative ; il élimine le superflu pour aller
à l’essentiel. « Pour bien écrire, disait-il, il
faut sauter les idées intermédiaires, assez pour
n’être pas ennuyeux ; pas trop, de peur de n’être
pas entendu ». En clair, il y a un équilibre à
trouver entre le laconisme et l’exhaustivité.
Voilà un auteur qui pense à son lecteur.
Maintenant, quelles sont les idées,
les idées proprement sociologiques
intéressantes dans De l’esprit des lois ?
Il y a pas mal de choses différentes dans ce
livre — sa cohérence laisse à
désirer — mais on peut grosso
modo le découper en 3 thèmes sociologiques :
1. la théorie des 3 types de gouvernements ;
2. les causes physiques de
l’évolution de la société ;
3. les causes morales de l’évolution des règles
de la société (mœurs, coutumes, lois).
Je vais vous résumer ce que Montesquieu dit
d’intéressant à propos de chaque thème.
Sa théorie des 3 types de gouvernements est
inspirée de la théorie de la Politique d’Aristote,
qui était la référence dominante de la
philosophie politique classique.
Voici les éléments que vous pouvez en retenir :
* Il y a 3 types de gouvernement, la république,
la monarchie, et despotisme. Donc
Montesquieu oppose fondamentalement
les gouvernements modérés (la
république et la monarchie) et
les gouvernements non modérés (le despotisme).
* La république, c’est lorsque le corps social
détient la souveraineté ; la monarchie, lorsqu’un
seul détient la souveraineté et qu’il l’exerce
dans le cadre de règles ; et enfin, le despotisme
c’est lorsqu’un seul détient la souveraineté MAIS
qu’il ne l’exerce pas dans le cadre de règles.
* Pour Montesquieu, chaque type de régime se
caractérise par un sentiment dominant dans les
relations entre les individus : le dévouement
à la collectivité dans la république ;
l’honneur dans la monarchie ; et enfin
la crainte dans le despotisme.
* Enfin, il précise que plus la
société est grande, plus l’autorité doit être
despotique. La dimension de la société est donc
un paramètre important à prendre en compte pour
choisir le type de gouvernement adapté.
C’est en parlant des types de gouvernements
que Montesquieu parle de la séparation des
pouvoirs — mais je ne vais pas développer
cette idée, parce qu’elle relève davantage
de la science politique. Sur le plan proprement
sociologique, cette idée signifie qu’il faut
rechercher l’équilibre des puissances sociales
pour que les hommes soient libres. On peut le
dire plus simplement en disant que la concurrence
des élites garantit la liberté des individus.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus sur l’idée de
la séparation des pouvoirs de Montesquieu,
allez lire ma synthèse sur le site 1000
idées de culture générale. Le lien est
dans la description de cette vidéo.
Je passe maintenant au thème de l’influence
des causes physiques sur la société.
Montesquieu pense que le milieu géographique
influence les institutions, MAIS PAS qu’il
les engendre nécessairement. Autrement dit,
le milieu géographique est un facteur important,
mais seulement un facteur. Il ne fait qu’orienter
les institutions dans une certaine direction.
L’idée la plus importante de ce thème, c’est que
le climat (froid ou chaud, modéré ou extrême)
favorise une certaine manière d’être. Pour
Montesquieu, par exemple, les gens recherchent
plus les plaisirs dans les pays chauds — moins
dans les pays froids. À climat différent, société
probablement différente, donc. Montesquieu évoque
également les facteurs de la fertilité
des terrains et de la démographie.
Je passe maintenant au dernier thème sociologique,
l’influence des causes morales sur les règles qui
existent dans la société, qu’il s’agisse
des mœurs, des coutumes, ou des lois.
La distinction entre ces 3 types de règles
est une idée capitale du thème.
Voici la différence fondamentale :
* Les mœurs sont des règles implicites, imposées
par la société (comme diront les sociologues),
et ces règles dictent la conduite intérieure de
l’homme. Par exemple, la fidélité au conjoint
fait partie de ce qu’on appelle les « bonnes
mœurs » dans la plupart des sociétés.
* Ensuite, les coutumes sont elles aussi des
règles implicites, mais contrairement aux mœurs,
elles dictent la conduite extérieure de l’homme.
Par exemple, la poignée de main pour dire bonjour
est une coutume dans les sociétés occidentales.
* Enfin, les lois sont des règles formulées
explicitement, donc imposées par l’État,
et elles servent à dicter la conduite
extérieure du citoyen. Par exemple,
l’obligation de porter la ceinture de sécurité
en voiture est une loi (en France, elle date de
1973 pour ce qui est du conducteur).
Montesquieu avance que ces 3 types de
règles reflètent l’« esprit général d’une
nation », c’est-à-dire la manière d'être,
d'agir, de penser et de sentir d'une collectivité
particulière, telle que l'ont faite la géographie
et l'histoire. Ce concept d’esprit général,
c’est un peu ce qu’est la culture pour les
anthropologues américains, c’est-à-dire
l’ensemble des productions de l’esprit
et des valeurs d’un groupe humain.
Ce concept montre bien que Montesquieu a
une perspective sociologique : la société est
un tout, un ensemble qui doit être étudié en
tant que tel.
________________
2ème référence : Cours de philosophie
positive, Auguste Comte
Qu’est-ce que cette référence fait dans ma liste
? Vous pouvez déjà être sceptiques parce qu’il
y a le mot « philosophie » dans le titre, ce qui
semble indiquer que c’est un livre de philosophie,
et non pas de sociologie. Vous pouvez être
d’autant plus sceptiques qu’Auguste Comte n’a
presque pas eu d’influence en sociologie,
et on s’est même plutôt moqué de lui,
parce qu’il a élaboré des plans précis de ses
rêves (avec par exemple le nombre d’hommes
de chaque cité, les fonctions de chacun et
les détails de la hiérarchie sociale).
Et pourtant, le Cours de philosophie positive
fonde véritablement la sociologie en tant que
science. Pourquoi ? Parce qu’Auguste Comte y pose
clairement la priorité du tout sur l’élément (en
l’occurrence de la société sur l’individu) et
la nécessité de comprendre l’élément À PARTIR
DU TOUT. On retrouve bien là l’ambition qui
définit la sociologie, étudier la société comme
un tout qui a ses propriétés propres.
Comte arrive à cette nouvelle perspective
intellectuelle en partant d’une autre science, la
biologie. Quand on cherche à comprendre un organe,
on ne peut pas le faire sans considérer
l’être vivant en entier — eh bien c’est
pareil pour comprendre l’être humain, on ne
peut pas le faire sans considérer le groupe
humain dans son ensemble.
Une autre raison pour laquelle
le Cours de philosophie positive mérite d’être
considéré comme une référence de sociologie,
c’est que Comte, contrairement à Montesquieu,
parle de la société industrielle qui émerge
à son époque. Il s’intéresse donc déjà aux
mutations sociales auxquelles réfléchiront
les premiers sociologues professionnels.
Sur la forme, le Cours de philosophie positive
est un livre très long : il y a 6 tomes, ce
qui représente environ 3500 pages. Mais bien
sûr personne ne lit la totalité de ces 3500 pages,
c’est pourquoi le livre n’est, à ma connaissance,
pas disponible en version papier. En plus d’être
très long, il est désagréable à lire : le style de
Comte est lourd ; ses phrases sont longues,
et les répétitions fatiguent le lecteur.
Personne ne lui a expliqué qu’il faut user des
adjectifs et des adverbes avec parcimonie.
Que retenir de cette référence
sur le fond, maintenant ?
La thèse sociologique fondamentale d’Auguste
Comte est que toute société tient par l'accord
des esprits. Cela veut dire que les hommes ne
peuvent s’assembler que dans la mesure où ils
partagent les mêmes croyances. Ça doit vous
rappeler le concept de « réalité imaginaire
» si vous avez lu le best-seller Sapiens.
Mais Auguste Comte n’est pas le premier à
dire que la vie collective se construit sur des
conventions (c’est une idée très ancienne).
Une fois qu’on a mis en évidence le fait que toute
société tient par l'accord des esprits, on doit se
demander : comment cet accord évolue-t-il ?
En reconstituant le progrès du savoir
scientifique, Auguste Comte met en
évidence la loi qui préside à l’évolution
des mentalités, la loi des 3 états.
En premier lieu, l’esprit humain opérait à
l’état théologique, caractéristique du Moyen-Âge
et de l’Ancien Régime. Dans cet état, la réflexion
est focalisée sur la recherche de l’essence de
l’univers et les hommes pensent que c’est Dieu
qui cause les bouleversements sociaux. L’esprit
humain serait ensuite passé à l’état métaphysique,
caractéristique de l’esprit des Lumières et
des encyclopédistes, où s’épanouissent les
croyances en des entités ou des abstractions (le
contrat social de Rousseau, par exemple). Enfin,
l’esprit humain parvient à l’état dit « positif
», ou scientifique, à partir duquel il renonce
à trouver l’essence du réel pour se borner à
rechercher les seules lois de la nature.
L’adjectif « positif » s’oppose à « hypothétique
», et il qualifie ce qui repose sur les faits.
Fondamentalement, il sert à signaler un
idéal de fiabilité supérieure pour le savoir,
par opposition aux savoirs théologique et
métaphysique, qui n’étaient pas le produit
de la méthode scientifique moderne chère à
Auguste Comte, qui était polytechnicien.
Cette façon de penser, dite « positive », qui
a triomphé en mathématiques, en astronomie, en
physique, en chimie et en biologie — cette façon
de penser doit, selon Comte, s'imposer finalement
en matière de politique, et aboutir à la
constitution d'une science positive de la société,
LA SOCIOLOGIE. La manière dont je comprends cette
idée, c’est que la science moderne a transformé
la philosophie politique en sociologie.
Une autre idée intéressante, et plus précise,
c’est que le triomphe de la mentalité
positive change les fonctions,
et donc la hiérarchie, dans la société :
les savants vont remplacer les prêtres,
et les industriels (au sens large) les hommes de
guerre. Nouvelle société, nouvelles élites.
Je termine avec une petite anecdote.
Après le livre dont je vous ai parlé,
le Cours de philosophie positive, Auguste Comte
donnera à sa théorie la dimension d’une religion,
qu’il appellera la « religion de l’Humanité ».
Il imaginera que la mentalité positive issue de
la maturité des sciences — il imaginera que cette
mentalité unira l’humanité autour des mêmes dogmes
scientifiques. Et la dimension anecdotique de ce
prolongement théorique, c’est qu’il lui aurait
été inspiré par son aventure (très platonique)
avec une jeune femme, 17 ans plus jeune que lui
et fervente catholique, Clotilde de Vaux.
Comme l’avait reconnu Comte lui-même, le sentiment
est le seul vrai moteur de l’action.
________________
3ème référence : De la démocratie
en Amérique, Tocqueville
Pourquoi ce livre est-il dans ma liste ?
Parce que c’est l’analyse de référence,
dans l’histoire de la pensée occidentale,
de la société démocratique.
Certes, Tocqueville n’est pas considéré comme un
inspirateur de la pensée sociologique — d’ailleurs
c’est pendant mes études de philosophie à la
Sorbonne, il y a de cela une dizaine d’années,
que j’ai découvert De la démocratie en Amérique.
Mais cette analyse de la société démocratique
est véritablement sociologique dans la
mesure où la perspective intellectuelle
est holiste : Tocqueville réfléchit du point
de vue de la société prise comme un tout,
comme un ensemble irréductible à ses parties.
Son idée centrale est révélatrice de la dimension
sociologique du livre : la démocratie n’est
pas un régime politique, un certain type de
pouvoir ; c’est un certain type de société.
La perspective intellectuelle est également
originale pour 2 autres raisons :
1. c’est un Français, magistrat dans
un vieux pays donc, qui parle de l’Amérique, une
jeune nation où il a voyagé (Tocqueville y avait
été envoyé par le gouvernement français pour
enquêter sur le système carcéral américain) ;
2. c’est un aristocrate, issu d’une
vieille famille de la noblesse de
Normandie, qui parle de la démocratie.
En clair, Tocqueville est culturellement très
étranger à la société qu’il analyse.
C’est peut-être cette extériorité qui
lui a permis d’être si pénétrant.
Que dire de De la démocratie en Amérique
sur la forme ? L’essai est divisé en 2
livres — le 1er avait été publié en 1835,
le 2nd en 1840. Au total, il y en a pour 1000
pages. Mais ces 1000 pages sont très lisibles
par rapport aux livres des futurs sociologues
professionnels. Tocqueville était soucieux de son
style, et il le travaillait en suivant l’idéal
d’éloquence du français classique, qui combine
la simplicité et ce qu’on appelle « le naturel
». Son effort de clarté se décèle aussi sur le
plan de l’organisation du propos : il traite une
idée à la fois. On peut donc dire que la forme du
livre est « démocratique » dans la mesure où elle
rend le fond accessible au plus grand nombre.
Quoi retenir du fond, maintenant ?
Pour commencer, la matière des 2 tomes
est un peu différente. Le 1er tome analyse la
démocratie américaine de manière descriptive. Le
2nd élargit la perspective en montrant comment
la démocratie change la société civile.
L’idée centrale de De la démocratie en Amérique,
encore une fois, c’est que la démocratie n’est
pas seulement un régime politique, mais
plus fondamentalement une nouvelle société,
où les relations entre les hommes sont
animées par des valeurs différentes.
Et la valeur cardinale de cette nouvelle société,
c’est L’ÉGALITÉ. L’égalité des conditions est
la caractéristique majeure de la démocratie
américaine. Ce n’est pas seulement un idéal,
un principe politique et juridique — c’est la
passion, la valeur suprême des Américains ; c’est
leur mentalité. Ils voient le monde et conçoivent
leurs tâches, droits et devoirs dans ce monde
sous le prisme de l’égalité démocratique.